>>> TOLD YOU AT THE TOP OF THE
PROGRAM ABOUT THE FDA'S DECISION
TO FULLY APPROVE THE PFIZER
COVID VACCINE AND HOW IT MIGHT
CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE, AT LEAST MANY OF THEM
WHO HAVE BEEN ON THE FENCE ABOUT
GETTING ONE.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SPOKE AT AN
ALABAMA RALLY OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHILE HE RECEIVED HIS USUAL
FULL-THROATED WELCOME, WHEN IT
CAME TO THE VACCINE, MANY WHO
CAME TO HEAR HIM HAD NO SUPPORT
FOR EITHER THE VACCINE OR HIM
TELLING THEM THEY SHOULD GET THE
VACCINE, WHICH HE DID.
DONIE O'SULLIVAN WAS THERE AND
HE TALKED TO THE SUPPORTERS
ABOUT THE VACCINES AT THE TIME
PENDING APPROVAL.
HERE'S HIS REPORT.
>> NO.
NOT GETTING THAT VACCINE.
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
THEM VACCINES ARE NOT GOOD, HON.
>> ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> NO.
BUT I HAVE A LOT OF HYDRO
ENCLOSURE QUINN AT MY HOUSE.
>> HAVE YOU GOT YOUR VACCINE?
>> NO.
DON'T WANT IT.
>> NO?
>> THEY AIN'T TESTED IT ENOUGH
IN MY OPINION.
>> THE PFIZER SHOT IS ABOUT TO
GET FULL FDA APPROVAL.
WOULD THAT CHANGE YOUR OPINION
ON IT AT ALL?
>> NOT UNTIL THEY DO A WHOLE LOT
MORE INVESTIGATING IN ON IT.
>> YEAH.
>> NOTHING IS GOING IN ME UNTIL
THEN.
>> RIGHT.
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD TAKE A
LONG TIME?
>> ABOUT TEN YEARS OR SO.
>> I DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT,
I DON'T TRUST CDC, I DON'T TRUST
NONE OF THEM.
>> WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE
VACCINE --
>> BECAUSE I'VE WATCHED DR.
10PENNY AND SHE'S DONE A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON IT.
>> Reporter: SHE IS A
DISCREDITED CONSPIRACY THEORIST
WHO PUSHES DANGEROUS
MISINFORMATION ABOUT VACCINES.
>> I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN THE
PICTURES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THESE SHOTS AND NOW THEY'RE
MAGNETIZED.
THEY CAN PUT SPOONS AND FORKS
ALL OVER THEM AND THEY STICK.
>> Reporter: THOSE CLAIMS LANDED
HER ON A LIST KNOWN AS THE
DISINFORMATION DOZEN,
SUPERSPREADERS OF COVID
MISINFORMATION.
>> THESE 12 PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE
GIVING MISINFORMATION.
ANYONE LISTENING TO IT IS
GETTING HURT BY IT.
IT'S KILLING PEOPLE.
IT'S BAD INFORMATION.
>> Reporter: BUT TENPENNY AND
OTHERS IN THE DISINFORMATION
DOZEN ARE FINDING APPEAL AMONG
SOME TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
>> MY OWN DOCTOR TRIED TO GET ME
TO GET THE SHOT AND I TOLD HIM
TO GO WATCH DR. TENPENNY.
>> SO YOU TRUST THIS WOMAN ON
THE INTERNET MORE THAN YOUR OWN
DOCTOR?
>> UH-HUH, I DO.
>> TO LISTEN TO THE INTERNET OR
LISTEN TO -- RATHER THAN THE
PROFESSIONALS, THE SCIENTISTS,
THE CDC, THE FDA, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OF VACCINE, IT'S
BEEN, AGAIN, THE GREATEST GIFT
WE'VE EVER BEEN GIVEN.
PEOPLE TODAY WOULDN'T BE AT ANY
OF THESE EVENTS, THEY WOULD
EITHER HAVE POLIO, THEY WOULD
HAVE SMALLPOX, THEY WOULD HAVE
MANY OTHER DISEASES.
VACCINES HAVE SAVED US.
>> Reporter: TRUMP CAME HERE TO
ALABAMA SATURDAY.
IT'S THE STATE WITH THE LOWEST
VACCINATION RATE IN THE NATION
AND AT THE TIME OF THIS RALLY,
EVERY ICU BED HERE WAS FULL.
HIS TIMID SUGGESTION HIS
SUPPORTERS SHOULD GET THE SHOT
WAS MATCHED WITH JEERS.
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT, I BELIEVE
TOTALLY IN YOUR FREEDOMS, I DO.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO WHAT YOU HAVE
TO DO.
BUT I RECOMMEND, TAKE THE
VACCINES.
I DID IT, IT'S GOOD.
TAKE THE VACCINES.
BUT YOU'VE GOT -- NO, THAT'S
OKAY.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR FREEDOMS.
BUT I HAPPEN TO TAKE THE
VACCINE.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK, YOU'LL BE
THE FIRST TO KNOW, OKAY?
>> TRUMP GOT THE VACCINE,
THOUGH.
>> THEY KEEP SAYING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT.
I MEAN I'M NOT FULLY CONVINCED
OF THAT.
>> YOU DON'T THINK TRUMP GOT IT?
>> I DON'T THINK HE DID.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> Reporter: IN SO MANY PEOPLE'S
MINDS, SO MANY PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WANT TO GET THE SHOT, THIS IS A
REPUBLICAN/DEMOCRAT THING.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, BUT I WILL TELL YOU I
DON'T PERSONALLY SEE THAT THAT
VIRUS CAME OVER HERE ON A DUON
KEY OR ELEPHANT AND IT'S
AFFECTING EVERYBODY.
>> I WATCH PROPHETS OF GOD AND
NEWSMAX AND MAYBE A LITTLE FOX,
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
I'VE KIND OF TURNED AWAY FROM
NEWS.
I DON'T WANT TO LISTEN TO IT.
I WANT TO LISTEN TO WHAT GOD IS
SAYING, WHAT HE'S FIXING TO DO.
THAT'S ALL I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
I THINK IT IS TIME WHERE GOD IS
SEPARATING THE SHEEPS FROM THE
GOATS.
>> Reporter: WHAT ARE YOU?
>> I'M A GOAT BECAUSE I AIN'T A
SHEEP.
I'M NOT DOING WHAT THEY TELL ME
TO DO.
I'M FIGHTING AGAINST IT.
>> DONIE O'SULLIVAN JOINS US
NOW.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAYING THAT HE GOT THE
SHOT, ALTHOUGH YOU SAID IT WAS
TIMID, NEVERTHELESS HE DID SAY
IT.
DO YOU THINK IT CONVINCED
ANYONE?
>> Reporter: NO, IT DIDN'T SEEM
LIKE THAT, ANDERSON.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
TRUMP KNOWS.
WE KNOW TRUMP LIKES TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR THINGS AND HE CAN IN
MANY RESPECTS TAKE CREDIT FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS VACCINE,
BUT HE KNOWS THAT SO MANY IN HIS
BASE DO NOT WANT TO TAKE THIS
SHOT.
IT IS A RED LINE FOR THEM.
AND IT'S REALLY REMARKABLE TO
HEAR, YOU KNOW, SO MANY FOLKS
WE'VE SPOKEN TO DO NOT WANT TO
BE AS THAT WOMAN DESCRIBED IT A
SHEEP.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE THIS
VACCINE.
THEY VIEW IT AS A POLITICAL
STATEMENT ALMOST.
AND SOME FOLKS ARE SO INTENT ON
NOT BECOMING PART OF THIS HERD
OF SHEEP, THEY'RE GOING AS FAR
AS TAKING MEDICINE FOR HORSES.
SO IT IS A VERY TROUBLING
SITUATION HERE.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIAL IN OUR PIECE,
SOME FOLKS ARE ONLY WILLING